the alternate form of the derivative of
the function f at a number a denoted by
f prime of a is given by this stuff
now this might look a little strange to
you but if you really think about what
it's saying it's really just taking the
slope of the tangent line
between a
comma f of a so let's imagine some
arbitrary function like this let's say
that that is i'll just write that's our
function f
that's our function f and so you could
have the point when x is equal to a this
is our x axis when x is equal to a this
is the point a
f of a
you notice a
and then we could take the slope between
that and some arbitrary point let's call
that x
so this is the point
x
f of x
f of x and notice this top the numerator
right here this is just our change in
the value of our function or you could
view that as the change in the vertical
axis so that would give you this
distance right over here
that's what we're doing up here in the
numerator
and then in the denominator
we're finding the change in our
horizontal
values horizontal coordinates that let
me do that a different color
that would give you
that so the change in the horizontal
that's this right over here and then
they're trying to find the limit as x
approaches a so as x gets closer and
closer and closer and closer to a
what's going to happen is is that when x
is out here we have this secant line we
have we're finding the slope of
this secant line but as x gets closer
and closer the secant lines better and
better and better approximate the slope
of the tangent line where the limit as x
approaches a but doesn't quite equal a
is going to be this is actually our
definition of our derivative or i guess
the alternate form of the derivative
definition and this would be the slope
of the tangent line if it exists
so with that all that out of the way
let's try to answer the question with
the alternative form of the derivatives
in aid make sense of the following limit
expression by identifying the function f
and the number
a
so right here they want to find the
slope of the tangent line at 5. here
they wanted to find the slope of the
tangent line at a so it's pretty clear
that a
is equal to
5 and that f of a
f of a is equal to 125.
now what about f of x
f of x
well here it's the limit of f of x minus
f of a well here's the limit as x to the
third
minus 125 and this makes sense if f of x
if f of x is equal to x to the third
then it makes sense that f of 5
f of 5 is going to be 5 to the third is
going to be 125.
and we're also taking up here the limit
as x approaches a here taking the limit
as x approaches
5. so the derivat so this is the
derivative of the function f of x is
equal to x to the third so let me write
that down in the green color
x to the third at the number x equals
at the number a is equal to five and so
we can imagine this
let's try to actually graph it just so
we can imagine it actually i'll do it
out here
where i have a little bit better
contrast with the colors
so let's say that is my y-axis
let's say that this is my
my x-axis i'm not going to quite draw it
to scale let's say this right over here
is the point 125 or y this is when y
equals 125. this is when
x is equal to 5 so they're clearly not
at the same scale
but the function is going to look
something it's going to look something
like this
we know what x to the third looks like
it looks something
something like
something
let me draw a little bit something like
this
we know it's going to look something
like this so here our a is equal to 5
our a is equal to 5. this point right
over here is
is 5
comma
and then we're taking the slope between
that point and an arbitrary x value and
an arbitrary or i should say an
arbitrary other point on the curve so
this right over here would be the point
we could call that x
comma x to the third we know that f of x
is equal to x to the third and let me
make it clear this is the graph of y is
equal to
y is equal to
x to the third and so this expression
right over here all of this this is the
slope between these two points
this is the slope between these two
points and as we take the limit as x
approaches five
so right now this is our x
as x gets closer and closer and closer
to five as it gets closer and closer to
five the secant lines are going to
better and better approximate the slope
of the tangent line at x equals at x
equals five so the slope of the tangent
line would look something which would be
even more it would look something like
something like that